to your point about the strikeouts for
nine for antonio it's
it's always been below a seven that's
really low but if you keep the ball down
reminds me a little bit of aaron cook
cook is not a high strikeout rate
pitcher what's interesting about senza
tala he's not the traditional synchro
ball pitcher it's not like he's throwing
with the sinker it's his fastball just
has late run late life haven smith will
lead things off pitch his line right to
josh fuentes went down to one knee to
get underneath that liner makes the play
one quick out for senzatella
how's that for positioning he did not
have to move and a good thing because he
didn't have any time to do anything
except put the glove up see the numbers
for mad bum in his nine starts this
season he has been going gangbusters
until that started at dodger stadium
only four innings but was pitching well
before he came out of that game his
third start against the rockies this
year one pretty good one not so good i'm
out topping the left fielder will lead
it off that's the curve ball and he gets
him to chase it off the plate what a
great pitch that was i mean that ball
started looked like it was over the
middle of the plate and it broke looked
like about two inches or three inches
off the plate well a chance for mad bum
first and third two outs he enjoys this
part of the game strike three called on
the inside corner buzzed him with a
fastball
and the diamondbacks clutch hitting
struggles continue puts a man in scoring
position with two outs in this scoreless
third
colorado turns the line up over here's
topia base hit up the middle diaz or out
third coming home throwing that
direction not gonna get him tapia into
second safely what nothing colorado
great base running by rybell he read
that throw from reddick which sailed
over the cut-off man he moves into
scoring position as he delivers diaz
well we talked about lineup construction
and sometimes
it's not
just where you are in a lineup it's
matchups and
you know lefties generally don't fare
all that well against madison bumgarner
but the two lefties in the rockies
lineup today charlie blackmon and rymel
tapia do and
tap with the two out rbi the rockies
were picking those up in bunches last
night tapia now at 250 this year against
left-hand pitching
1-1 and the runner's going and bumgarner
has him picked off
throws to third and tapia stopped 10
feet from the base and he was out boy he
just ran him out of a chance for a
bigger inning now colorado has two in
scoring position in the fourth well
here's a big moment now for brendan
rodgers he flares one to right field and
that'll drop for a base hit krone is in
here comes fuentes he scores it's a
two-run single for brendan rodgers
rocky's now lead three to nothing his
first hit
in 20-21
three-nothing colorado it's the first
walk issued by antonio rojas two singles
today and he'll cue one to the left side
fuentes has got it to rogers at second
for one the first for the double play
nice turn by brendan after a good feed
from fuentes five shutout innings for
senzatella you want to know outs to open
up the sixth inning in the batter's josh
reddy diamondbacks on this road trip
including the previous five and into
this ball game are three for 30 with
runners in scoring position swinging a
drive
deep right field going back blackman it
is one hop and against the wall escobar
will score peralta to third rbi double
josh reddick and the d-backs around the
board they trail 3-1
well i thought that ball might be out of
here just the way he put his head down
after he hit it
escobar scores easy i think peralta had
a hole just a little bit to see if
blackman was going to catch the ball
with a nice swing by reddick and now the
d-backs are
i mean they're in they're going right
now gotta see if steven folk can drive
in these rocks vote rolls over one to
first it's under the glove of crowd and
nobody's covering first or run scores
and everybody's safe
rogers was on the outfield grass to
glove that after it got by chrome but
nobody covered the bag and the d-backs
have cut the lead to one and have
runners at the corners with nobody out
first and third and it's now three to
two one ball and two strikes on josh van
meter swinging a fly ball to right field
blackman going back on the warning track
makes the catch
tagging and coming home to score is
redick and the d-backs have nodded this
game at three
work new ball game now another slider
another backup slider this time
van meter is able to reach out there and
hook it back to his pole field deep
enough to
drive home josh reddick tie the ball
game and he represents the potential go
ahead run for charlie blackmon this ball
crushed deep right field way back at god
for the sixth time in his career
blackman has taken mad bump deep
and the rockies back in front five to
three
touch them all time
for chuck nasty
his third of the year and charlie didn't
need the permission to swing at that
first pitch that was a bullet he has yet
to retire a batter in this inning two
runs already in on the blackman homer
base is full of rockies nobody got the
batter as garrett hempson
that's the second
there's one and the throw is not gonna
get
so the rocky score run it produces an
rbi
for garrett
and now the rockies lead is six to three
banner with one out is the catcher elias
diaz who has singled and scored and a
wild pitch
here comes fuentes
safe
bumgarner couldn't quite get there in
time
and it's 7-3
from arizona's perspective everything
that can go wrong in this inning
and they got something cooking to open
up the seven
big swing of the bat here
back in this game escobar to right field
and deep and it is gone
three run home run eduardo escobar and
the d-backs are back in it they trail
7-6 it's a one-run ball game once again
for escobar that's five home runs in his
last eight games young batting 259 he's
got four homers bases loaded two outs
flared towards left field tapia coming
on hustling he dives and he makes the
catch
rymel tapia
with an incredible diving catch to leave
the bases loaded the tying runs now in
scoring position tell martay is going to
take this at bat
and a miss he got him with the gas
and the rockies make it two in a row
over the diamondbacks